once lyme disease crosses the
blood-brain barrier not only does it
debilitate memory your ability to speak
and have a conversation
but it completely debilitates brain
function in all areas
life is worth living
and if you're not going to give up the
only thing to do is to push forward
everyone has something they deal with
it's okay to say your struggles
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best belief life and learn how you
can cope with lyme disease enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be a warrior with ally hilfiger when
i was seven years old
my family took a little vacation
somewhere on the east coast i don't
remember if it was the hamptons or
nantucket or you know one of those cute
little towns
and the only souvenir that i came back
with on that vacation was a seemingly
insignificant tick bite right here on my
tummy
so my mother
took the tick off with a little pair of
tweezers
put it into a plastic bag sent it off to
be tested and actually her precaution
and education at the time was pretty
advanced for a woman a mother living in
the 90s
so the test came back
negative
borderline
ultimately
i went undiagnosed
and untreated
so this was due to a major failure in
the testing protocols at the time which
sadly have not improved to this day as
well as doctors who did not know what to
look for
little did i know
the tick was carrying two very
debilitating diseases
lyme disease and bybesiosis which is
like the cousin to malaria so you can
imagine how terrible that is and what
many people don't know about lyme
disease
is that it can cause manic and psychotic
episodes just like the ones i
experienced or the one that i
experienced
once lyme disease crosses the
blood-brain barrier not only does it
debilitate memory your ability to speak
and have a
conversation but it completely
debilitates brain function in all areas
so you end up looking like a crazy bag
lady a psychiatrist in the hospital
connected all of the dots
and she suspected that i might be
dealing with untreated lyme disease
i told there was no way
although all of my previous slime tested
come up as inconclusive or negative she
still demanded that i go see another
doctor
so i went
the blood results came back
the results were through the roof
my body was riddled with lyme disease
and bybesia
now i felt like i had won the lottery i
really did
i thought oh my gosh the cure is upon me
i can take an easy course of antibiotics
and done
i had no idea there was no cure for
long-term lyme disease
no idea
the diagnosis was just one little
element of the process
so once i had this diagnosis which took
11 years many false negative results a
nervous breakdown
i was put on a very aggressive course of
antibiotics
horse pills
baskets of them
and i would take them and i would have a
major flare-up called a herxheimer
and i'd get a lot worse before getting
better
so six to nine months of being on these
treatments i finally finally felt like i
could take on the world that i could go
back out there and prove to myself and
others that i could still work hard
and i could make up for lost time
only to find myself crashing and burning
months later
this became a cycle of ups and downs
relapsing feeling better thinking i was
better
than relapsing all over again you can
imagine the frustration and
disappointment
i was on this roller coaster for seven
years
i had an iv in my arm into my heart for
seven months
traveling between europe and new york
attaching the iv on a hangar i had to
make a decision
do i want to live
or
do i want to die
you know i have this
vision of myself
possibly one day having a great life a
full life
out of bed
no longer vicariously living through the
travel channel but actually getting on
an airplane and going and experiencing
the world
maybe even becoming a mother
so
i decided that i'd give it one more shot
along with a lot of self-acceptance
discipline
self-love
i went and i tried everything and my
body responded extremely well
to aggressive homeopathic treatments
meditations
special diets
complete lifestyle change
any alternative form of medicine i
explored
now
i believe in this idea of having a
toolbox
we all need a toolbox in life right
and through my experiences i have gained
some of the coolest tools i believe
a lot of them are for free
they include
visualizing myself well and healed and
healthy and strong
written exercises such as written
intentions and focus wheels adapted from
abraham hicks adapted by sheila bath
i write about these in my book and on my
website
special diets and juices and tonics to
help lower inflammation
different diets
understanding
that the most important element
to dealing with this monster of a
disease and managing a chronic disease
that will always probably be in me
is that i not only have to keep myself
physically balanced
but also mentally
emotionally and spiritually balanced
i'm not perfect at it
i go up and down
i remember to
be forgiving of myself
love myself take good care of myself and
to say
you know life's too short i laugh at
myself
i remember that i have a amazing list of
friends who have wonderful perspectives
on life who i can call at any time and
say you know i'm really having a
horrible time i'm kind of falling into
self-doubt and them lifting me back up
i have a wonderful arsenal of healers
and doctors and therapists
and i'm sure mind body green can offer
us many more tools
so
the main point that i want to emphasize
today
and always
is that i'm no longer a victim
i'm a survivor
and i was able to transform
from being a victim
into a survivor
a healer
and a warrior will number two appreciate
each moment with avril lavigne being
that this is the first new album in five
years
um
five years of that was spent with you
having uh three years of that was spent
with you having lyme disease how has
your outlook on life changed
um
well
i'm glad i had like as much fun as i did
in the past like i used to always like
live every day like it was the full like
the la to the fullest like it was my
last day so i look back and i'm like i'm
glad
i really embraced
my career
and just like life and that was always
my approach and that still is my
approach
today
do i look at things differently yes and
no
i mean i think that i appreciate the
smaller things and the things that were
taken away from me at one point
i've come so far
and like
when i turn around and look at where i
was
as into where i am today like i fully
have my life back and i'm so
appreciative and grateful and
um
i feel like i always was though and i
always had a really good head on my
shoulders and worked really hard
to get to where i was like i was just
like this chick from a small town
in canada and i got here on my own with
like no connections so
i always felt really focused and
hard-working
i think if anything
just the small things and
random things are just so much brighter
yeah now but i also think that that just
comes with like life experience yeah too
and as we grow
we appreciate different stuff more
yeah
um does it affect your relationships and
friendships with people does it does it
make that difficult
um i think like at this point in my life
i just really know who my friends are
and i like to keep like a close small
group and um
yeah i learned a lot about friendships
and learning how to like lean on people
and um i just keep good people around me
i don't have
you know time or energy for anything
other than just good solid people i know
that you said that before too um that
you're a fan of shania another one of
our canadian gems
we spoke to her um about lyme and she
said that uh it affected her vocal cords
and really she had to get treatment and
stuff um and obviously your voice sounds
phenomenal on this album so um did that
ever become a concern
like your singing voice getting affected
um i think that
while i was recovering i had it was the
first time i'd ever had real time off so
um
yeah i was concerned when i would start
singing that maybe my voice because it's
a muscle would be like
not as strong but
you know
i was just really so passionate about
the songs yeah and when i got behind the
mic and i sang i was just so there and
so present just like energetically and
spiritually and just like everything and
like i opened my mouth to sing
and i feel like i'm kind of singing
better than ever you are but like it's
like it's everything it's cause like i'm
just so um
i'm so
in love with music all over again
i'm not doing it because i have to i'm
writing music and recording and
performing because i want to because
there is a love for it and like through
this entire experience of like getting
sick and going down and not being sure
whether
i was going to be making music or not
and like coming turning to music really
showed me how much i really do love it
and need it in my life rule number three
don't give up with justin bieber i've
realized after a series of tests that i
have what's called lyme disease which is
a super silent disease that's not really
very well known
doctors it's very hard for doctors to
test for it basically infections have
played a big part of my acne and my
overall toxins in my body which just
creates all this stuff so it feels good
now to know
why i feel so crappy all the time life
is worth living
and if you're not gonna give up the only
thing to do is to push forward
that's it rule number four share your
struggles with tory piskin i'm tori
piskin i do stand up i make videos i
have a podcast i have lyme disease in my
senior year of college i was having
blurry vision i was sleeping like 14
hours a day like it felt like the
exorcist like the devil was inside of me
something was just off i just felt it i
remember getting the diagnosis telling
my friend across the street it's lyme
disease and then she was like oh my dad
had it four times you're gonna be fine
and i just like keep playing that in my
head over and over again because it just
like really was never fine again
[Music]
lyme disease has been one word hell i
really thought it was just going to be
like a flu or something i had no idea it
was just going to be this like long
health journey
[Music]
i feel like lyme disease is kind of like
that guy you're not in a serious
relationship with but will like come in
and out of your life when he just feels
needy like up it's been a month
he texted me
he's tired he's having headaches and the
analogy's going over but you guys get
what i'm saying because i feel like it
just comes up out of nowhere and i have
like no idea when it's going to happen
i would say fatigue is the biggest
symptom i still deal with but it's not
like oh okay i'm getting tired it
literally feels like rocks are on you
when i used to have like a nine to five
job i would go to the bathroom and like
put my head on the toilet and then like
take a nap it also has these like awful
headaches it literally feels like
someone's in your brain with a hammer
like eight eight
numbness in the legs blurry vision you
know when you wake up in the middle of
the night and your eyes take a little
while to adjust i was having that
throughout the whole day
i think the hardest thing to treat is if
you have like neurological symptoms and
you don't really know how to describe
and you don't know why when it was
really bad it felt like i was in a scary
movie walking around the city and any
moment you feel like something's gonna
jump out that was just like another very
weird specific symptom that i was having
that i was like this isn't me i don't
know what the hell is going on but i
think with any autoimmune or anxiety
it's always a constant struggle and you
kind of learn how to deal with it
i started making a lot of videos because
i got a port put in my arm and then for
the next like eight to nine months i did
iv antibiotics i was bedridden and
that's when i started editing and making
all my own videos i would say it really
helped me find another part of my comedy
that maybe i would have not found before
the line and then he leaned in he's like
it's not contagious is it
and i liked it only for the ones that
don't text me back
so he has lyme disease now
no i've never experienced the symptoms
while performing even if i'm feeling
symptoms before the moment i get on
stage it like all goes away i've had
shows where i do my lyme disease jokes
and then people will come up to me and
they'll be like oh i actually have lyme
i've struggled with that it's like
really nice to hear someone else talk
about that
they do call it an invisible disease
because you don't look sick and i feel
like when i had the picc line it was the
one time people believed me that i was
sick because it was like oh this is
serious she has an iv hanging from her
arm
unfortunately lyme disease is like very
hard to detect people literally go years
thinking it's ms thinking it's lupus so
i feel so lucky that i got to get the
treatment i'm now freelancing i'm doing
videos i do comedy which is great
because they really can make my own
schedule if i need to like close my eyes
at four o'clock i can
everyone has something they deal with
it's okay to say your struggles
i feel like the best way to sign off as
someone with lyme disease is just to be
like signing off rule number five
persevere with shania twain you
contracted lyme disease which had a huge
impact on your voice was there a moment
to which you really thought you wouldn't
be able to sing again
there was a long time i thought i would
never sing again i it took years to get
to the bottom of what was affecting my
voice
um
and i would say probably a good seven
years before a doctor was able to find
out that it was
nerve damage to my um vocal cords
directly caused by lyme's disease and i
was just simply out horseback riding in
the forest and
got bit by a tick a lime tick
wow i mean that is it it's funny because
i mean i am not obviously a world famous
singer but i lost my voice for 18 months
and i totally get
when i read that you said it's so
debilitating you almost become
invisible don't you in in social
circumstances because it's such an
effort to speak
when you start avoiding um speaking on
the phone you start avoiding going to
places that have any
uh ambient noise where you have to speak
over the volume of others it's very
debilitating our voices is such a huge
part of our self-expression and for a
vocalist a singer obviously and for
somebody like yourself it's
uh devastating in
so many ways so
until i got to the bottom of why i was
having a problem with my voice i there
wasn't really much i could do about it
so it took a long time and i i did
believe that i would have to probably
accept at some point that i was never
going to be able to sing again
thankfully i was you know i persevered
and it's
i'm making records again and putting on
concerts so you had an operation didn't
you what did they
exactly do and i presume there was a
risk attached to that
of course it was very scary
but the surgeon
that did the surgery
had a cancer
throat cancer himself and had this very
operation
after damaging the nerves in his larynx
from the cancer operation
so it's an open throat surgery
they cut you open
and they insert
uh gore-tex
sort of like what i would consider or
explain um to be crutches
and they stabilize
the
uh weakness in the vocal cord functions
so
apparently
i will have these little gore-tex
crutches supports long after i'm
buried in the dust my voice has changed
my speaking voice is definitely the
biggest effort because you can hear him
i get quite raspy and
sometimes
i have to adjust make adjustments
um as i'm speaking but
singing because there's more projection
involved with singing singing is
actually easier
i have more power when i'm singing now i
i have more character i find and i i
enjoy singing again speaking is the more
difficult challenge for me than than
singing which
okay i'll take that my family's been so
incredibly supportive and
and you know also just through the
frustration before i i determined uh
what was wrong with my voice
i was you know it got me down i was um i
think that that was the part that needed
the most support once i was into
recovery
um i was feeling optimistic all of a
sudden and feeling a lot better about it
but it was it's been a long road
and i've had to rediscover my voice as
well
and also accept that um it will never be
the same
but i i i love my new voice i'm
i'm i'm grateful rule number six be
hopeful with yolanda foster i went from
being an outspoken multitasking social
butterfly
to being trapped in a mentally paralyzed
cocoon
two and a half years ago
i started going to my doctors
complaining about exhaustion
joint pain
insomnia but most importantly my
neurological malfunctions
i often said it feels like i have an
infection in my brain
i felt sick in my head
but unfortunately
my doctor
and doctor and doctor after doctor kept
telling me i was overworked and juggling
too many things at once
supposedly my blood work looked normal
so over and over again i was sent home
with more and more prescription drugs
like sleeping pills adderall steroids
and of course the fashionable
antidepressant
i was so not depressed
yes of course i was annoyed with feeling
stupid and exhausted during the day and
dealing with severe insomnia at night
but nevertheless
i was living the best time of my life
by pure discipline
loyalty and commitment to the show i
managed to finish my season on bravo tv
as a beverly hills housewife
[Applause]
the last night of filming i realized
that something was really wrong with me
as i was trying to defend
myself in an argument with one of the
cast members
would you know what they're like
it wasn't easy
but it did that moment was a defining
moment for me where i realized that i'd
gone
down
my brain was no longer able to pull
information to form sentences
i had no word retrieval and my memory
was blank
and as i answered her i said you're such
an [ __ ]
and you know in holland in my language
we don't even have that word we don't
even use it it's a word that i've never
used before and probably never will
again
but
so it was just that moment the light had
gone off in my brain and when i finally
released myself from being the tough
cookie that i am
my body just shut down my question is
where does one turn when diagnostic
testing in the u.s fails and doctors
keep sending people like us home with
prescription drugs to mask our symptoms
i ask this question to you not for me
but for the hundreds and thousands of
lime sufferers out there that have come
to this roadblock
we live in the most extraordinary
country with the best doctors in the
world but the truth is
we don't have proper diagnostic testing
and there is no defined treatment
protocol or cure for chronic lyme
disease
as hard as this journey has been for me
i feel i was given this experience for a
reason
i'm here to represent all my fellow
limeys
we will no longer allow this disease to
terrorize our lives
we must break this island we must speak
up
for those who cannot be heard we must
restore hope for those who have given up
and we must share our stories with the
world and rule number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
find the right doctor with linda ali i
awakened one morning in 1984
with
multiple symptoms that included a stiff
neck a temperature of 103 a migraine
headache chills sore throat i literally
was not able to lift my head off the
pillow
i was so ill that my family doctor made
a house call
and chose to treat me with
10 to 12 days of antibiotics feeling
that i had the flu
and
the antibiotics did allow me to feel
better and resume my normal activities
in a normal life until three months
later i began with many many bizarre
symptoms continuation of migraine
headaches
muscle twitching all over my body
extreme insomnia
uh
fatigue that was unrelenting
just a plethora of symptoms that
continued to progress
i was finally diagnosed nine years ago
with lyme disease i saw probably 15
doctors all ending with ologists because
my symptoms involved so many systems of
my body i had heart palpitations
my eyes were affected my hearing was
affected my nerves were affected my
joints were affected my brain
and
no one was really able to identify
exactly what it was including the head
of rheumatology at hopkins who said she
didn't think this was rheumatoid
arthritis and i kept saying that i felt
that it was lyme disease because i have
a history of over probably well over a
hundred tick infestations
from living at our summer cottage in the
woods for so many years but
no one thought it was lyme in all
honesty because i had a delay in
treatment for 20 years
i did not
see a significant difference with the
antibiotic treatment and symptoms
continued to progress so it was after a
long period of time that i chose to
stop antibiotic treatment and found a
physician who treats more naturally
with herbal preparations
and it's because i changed the protocol
that i am beginning to finally see some
improvement in
in the pain and my quality of life i
have a wonderful
doctor that
has allowed me to be an active
participant in making
responsible decisions about my own
health and well-being
and again as i stated earlier i would
not go to a doctor that i couldn't have
a doctor-patient relationship where i
was an equal partner i have
declined some medications that i've been
not willing to take the risk and other
times i'm very open and my doctor has
just worked with me and listened very
closely
and honored and respected my wishes
and that's the way that a doctor-patient
relationship should be
so finding the right doctor that knows
the importance of treating long term
using different treatment modalities not
just necessarily antibiotics it is the
key to a person's health and well-being
because had i been treated
appropriately and diagnosed early i
would like to believe that i wouldn't
have had 14 joint related surgeries and
six total joint replacements and these
surgeries began when i was 40 years old
the only thing that makes sense out of
pain and suffering is to be able to find
purpose and meaning for your suffering
so when i stopped my nursing career when
i ended it as a parish nurse after 16
years it wasn't very long until god
nudged me and said you need to start a
local support group because we had none
in the harrisburg area
so i was led to start the support group
in 2009
and it brought such meaning and purpose
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
another side of dial you might not know
about is he's struggling despite all
that money with something called lyme
disease an illness he says you should
know about because it could happen to
you how did you find out you had it well
you find out you have it if suddenly
you're down on the floor is really what
i had what's all about i had some
gradual things i was noticing
things like increasing allergic reaction
to things like things i was never
allergic to i suddenly became allergic
to uh like extreme like things like
celery of all weird things you know i
that got broke out my eyes swelled up
all kinds of strange things like that i
started getting tremors uh i started
this came on when how many uh this came
on about two and a half years ago and
then one day i woke up and i had this
really bad fever
um
extreme exhaustion
really stiff all over my whole body
again the tremors started did they think
something like mls or other neurological
well that early i didn't know what i had
you know i went to a couple doctors i
went to the doctor my normal doctor and
said well maybe you have a summer flu
you know they catch all summer flu and
uh i went well okay and then this but it
wasn't going away
and uh
then my uh
ex-girlfriend sarah allen
suggested that maybe i get tested for
lyme disease because she's had about
with lyme's disease and i uh
and i and i did that and i went online
and i found uh
i found out i got a really fast
education about it and i went on a line
uh because i was told to go to a person
named joseph burriscano who is a what i
consider to be an expert in the field
because he's been on in the front lines
of lyme disease for
and he said
slime it's not an ass or anything else i
read his right his internet thing and
then i i luckily i was i came back my
test i i was tested i came back with i
had erlichiosis which is one tick
related disease that happened to pop up
uh then i went to joe barascano who who
has a practice had a practice in in in
the hamptons and uh i found out that i
was co-infected and then i actually had
four tick-related diseases borrelia
babisia bibisi is a malaria like one
bartonella which is cat scratch fever
but this is serious stuff you're a lot
of real diseases ah it's not that
serious you're saying this is seriously
address what happened this is serious
stuff i mean i don't think people really
do understand now if especially if you
have what we call chronic lyme disease
which means if you're co-infected or
you've had it for a while if you get if
you get bit by a tick you could probably
and and you're lucky enough to have just
lyme's disease uh you can go get
doxycycline or whatever and if you can
get a doctor to give it to you and
you'll be almost sure to be cured
your chances are very good but the thing
is that lyme disease doesn't come up in
normal tests so it's probably a lot more
people have it and don't know how about
hundreds of thousands of people have it
and don't know it what's the worst
second duty
well it can pretty much kill you i mean
people have died from it and and so what
do you do and if you don't die
yeah you go on a long-term medication
how can you go on tours and do well
stuff you do it's hard i i i i was
in none in
inundating myself with antibiotics
basically and i i had
six months where i couldn't much do
anything
and uh and somehow i don't know through
willpower through good medical whatever
just luck various things i got myself
back together again and i'm on the road
to recovery and uh i'm i'm in pretty
good shape right now hey guys what's
going on my name is nick carlson i'm the
founder of vanguard marketing group and
i actually help evan with a lot of his
marketing off of youtube so things like
funnel design and implementation and
copywriting and email marketing and
launch planning paid media buying on
other platforms other than youtube and a
lot of things of that nature and evan
asked me to come and film a segment for
this video because of the role that lyme
disease has played in my life how it's
affected me my family you know our close
friends and he wanted me to share a
little bit about my story and some of my
biggest takeaways from dealing with this
disease for the last 20 plus years and
so a little bit of a background about me
i grew up in connecticut which was the
epicenter for lime i mean myself my
entire family my immediate family my
entire extended family every friend that
i grew up with we have all contracted
lyme in some form or another many of us
thankfully were able to overcome the
disease and at least cause it to go
dormant but many of us weren't and as a
result have been struggling with this
disease for 20 plus years as well as
all of the various
and
other diseases that can be spurred on
by lyme the person in my life who was
who was most most affected by it is my
mom i have been
her primary caregiver since i was eight
years old because she got lyme disease
um a long long time ago and it was you
know not that it is unfortunately much
more researched now but back then it was
almost no one knew about it and so she
got lyme disease it manifested itself as
rheumatoid arthritis in you know a few
joints in her body and so we went into
specialists they convinced us that it
was not lyme and they told us that it
was you know just rheumatism and as a
result they tried to treat the
rheumatism and they pumped her full of
all kinds of drugs and as a result it
actually inflamed the lyme disease and
it caused the rheumatism to spread
to every joint in her body literally
there is not a joint that she is not
affected affected by for those of you
who don't know rheumatoid arthritis is a
degenerative disease um it essentially
tricks your body into thinking or it
tricks your body into attacking itself
and essentially deteriorating its joints
it is degenerative there is no cure so
unfortunately the longer that you live
the worse it gets people with with her
condition as severe as she has it
typically don't make it for more than
than five or six years and thankfully
you know she is going on
21 years now with it and for the most
part has had you know a phenomenal
quality of life and has been able to
actually be present and witness a lot of
things that she wouldn't have otherwise
been able to experience especially with
you know myself growing up and you know
family members and just things of that
nature and one of the
i i guess i have three
primary takeaways or three
things that just over the years have
really
really stuck out to me as in is
majorly important components of
overcoming or managing or coping uh with
this disease and the first one is
definitely and i think someone in this
video might have actually mentioned this
as well but it's really
imperative that you find the right
doctor that you find the right
specialist because i cannot tell you
how many different doctors living in
connecticut living in california how
many different doctors and specialists
that we have gone to see who
have known nothing about lyme disease
and who have tried to
time and time and time again tell us
that it's not possible that it's lyme
disease it's in that it's you know lyme
disease doesn't affect people like this
and that they've turned us down um they
have they have treated us poorly and
they have made it very very difficult
for her to find
treatment it's not their fault it's
unfortunately a very misunderstood
disease that doesn't get a lot of
exposure it's one of the things i'm so
thankful for evan for even
putting this video together but finding
the right doctor somebody who can
be empathetic to your situation
who
can make sure that they're
trying or prescribing the right
medications or treatments and because
lyme really does manifest itself so
differently in so many different people
and you have to find a doctor who is
willing to kind of test and and figure
out exactly how you're being affected
and what will what will exacerbate or
inflame the lyme but also you know what
will help deal with the symptoms that
it's presenting itself as also a doctor
who knows what tests to run what markers
to look for there are very few tests out
there right now that are actually
designed to be able to even pick this
this disease up so finding a doctor or a
specialist who really really really
knows his stuff and is willing to really
make this long haul with you because it
is for some people again you can
overcome it for many this may be
a lifetime thing that you're dealing
with and you really really want somebody
in your corner and i'll i'll tell you
it's a little anecdote
i've been to so many doctors with her
over the last 20 years and i'll never
ever forget we went to
um one pain management specialist at one
point and she was obviously in chronic
pain and he literally turned his way he
said i don't believe you have lyme
disease i'm not going to prescribe you
painkillers i'm dea for he's a former
dea agent he said i'm dea first i'm
doctor second and i don't trust you or
your son and i think you've come in with
you know
a lie like a load of
so just if you come up against that keep
going keep finding them there are
phenomenal people out there you really
just have to try to dig the second thing
is that you really have to be adaptive
with the situation with my mom again so
many people with her condition don't
make it past five years let alone 21.
and every single doctor every time she's
had to go to the hospital every nurse
every every everybody has always said
the exact same thing i have never dealt
with somebody in your particular
situation i've never
met someone as fragile as you i've never
had to deal with a lot of the
the caveats that come with with this
disease
and we have been able to one of the
reasons that she has been able to live
and and you know again with the quality
of life for as long as she has for so
long is because
we've taken so many things into our own
hands and we've created all kinds of
adaptive measures and different things
that just make life easier for us
that no one's ever seen before from
different ways that she's able to get
food in and out of bed different ways to
be able to turn her lights and
television on and change the channel and
go to the bathroom and see people or
talk to people or use you know smart
phones and devices and things like that
and we've come up with very unique and
innovative ways to adapt to the disease
as it progresses that has allowed her to
still participate in a lot of things
that that many people in her position or
condition can't anymore and so being
adaptive to the disease and what happens
as it progresses is really really
important and then the third one
is which may sound cliche or may sound
you know like
duh just don't give up on them
really that is the one of the saddest
things that i've seen over the years and
that's that family members and friends
while they mean really really well in
the beginning even going to doctor's
appointments and and visiting and and
seeing things you know it's
one
hard to deal with being constantly told
that you're
not sick or that you're there's nothing
we can do and it's also it can be hard
for you know the friend or whomever or
the family member to come
and see somebody
in that condition and a lot of the time
they don't know what to do and so maybe
they just stop showing up for that
person or they disappear you don't hear
from them or if they just again and they
just disappear and so the biggest thing
for people with this disease who are
already fighting such an uphill battle
of just getting doctors and
practitioners to believe in what they're
suffering with is is to make sure that
you stick with them and make sure that
you show them support and help them the
best that you can even if you can't do
much just calling and saying hey is is
huge and just being a support system for
them because otherwise out of experience
it does get very lonely very very quick
and before you know it you have
very few or
nobody to turn to and it's it's really
just because people don't understand
understand the disease how to deal with
it and how to deal with somebody who who
is in so much pain all the time and what
they're dealing with so those are my
three biggest takeaways from from having
been experiencing this for so so long um
and i'll just to recap you know find the
right doctor be as adaptive as humanly
possible and you know never stop
supporting them and showing up for them
thank you guys
so much for making it to this part of
the video it means so much to me and so
much to everybody who has suffered with
this for as long as they have and you
know thank you evan again so much for
putting something like this together to
bring more awareness to this so thanks
guys talk to you soon
[Music]
if you want to know how you can make
adhd your superpower check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you can be smart and
successful and still struggle with add
just like i do my favorite rule is never
worry alone with the hyperactive
component of adhd